race is not a conduit for
communication right you see you could
that song is actually communication
right and communicating to white people
uh black people Hispanics Asians so what
you find out and what we have to
understand is that we are individuals uh
we do not think or communicate as groups
we are individuals when we communicate
to other people and that means
individuals within separate groups
can have as much in common or even more
in common with individuals in other
groups a white guy can have more in
common with the black guy right that's
it that's what this is really about so
when you look at that this is like it to
me it it's sad because it tells me what
we could have had for the longest time
if we didn't have this grotesque
monstrous thing called the media uh
there are all these major themes in life
and pigment doesn't change our shared
aspirations for these themes
unfortunately the media does yeah
do you think
that
these media Representatives that Greg
talks about why why can't they Embrace
this song is it what is negative in this
song
well in particular this line jumped out
at me and I didn't read anything about
it first when I this is the first time
that I've discussed it I was like I'm
just going to listen to the song so
there was one thing that stuck out to me
in a really positive way and one thing
that was more negative and then when I
read the criticism I saw it so this line
Lord we got folks in the street and got
nothing to eat and the obese milking
welfare so obviously it's picking on fat
people that's the fat phobic criticism
but it is using this classic Welfare
Queen Trope that goes back to the 90s
and it I don't think it's racially
charged there are people of all Races
that are on welfare a lot of them are
heavy and we we all know that those that
felt cruel to me but the thing that
stuck out in the positive direction and
why imagine that there was so much
emotional reaction to this was the line
about how long your hours are and how
hard you're working for the BS pay he
obviously used the expletive there and
it made me think back to the time when
we had Bernie Sanders and Donald Trump
talking about the same things in the
2016 primary and they were tapping into
this economic populism argument that was
really resonating with far lefties and
people on the right side of the spectrum
and it was this idea that that the deck
is permanently stacked against you it
doesn't matter what you do you can work
24 hours a day but your check will
always be garbage and you will never be
able to get out of this system that
doesn't want you to succeed and so I
thought that that was the main thrust of
why it's resonating with so many people
I assume across a political Spectrum as
well but I do think
this felt far less polarizing to me than
for instance the Jason Aldean song that
we were talking about just you know a
month and a half ago or whatever it is
about the small town and you know try it
here with the images of what was going
on in the summer of BLM this had a lot
of real working class Vibe and I get it
but I don't like the welfare queen stuff
yeah but that's his that's his feelings
but he's an artist and he can say what
he wants to say restricted from his own
experience
and what he sees as a problem in the
country obviously a lot of people you
know relate to what he's seeing and he
has every right to express himself and
his music you know however he wants and
if people want to jump on him for it but
I think there's a I mean obviously
there's a huge obesity problem in the
country yeah but obviously and they're
not stealing from the simply unhealthy
yeah and everybody knows it so you know
I see him calling it out as he sees it
as an artist so
um but it's fascinating to watch the
reaction to this baby on one song and
get so many people talking and thinking
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else